one of the great contributing factors to
mental illness is the idea that we
should at all costs and at all times be
well
we suffer far more than we should
because of how long it can take many of
us until we allow ourselves to fall
properly and usefully ill
in a crisis
our chances of getting better rely to a
significant extent on having the right
relationship to our illness
an attitude which is relatively
unfrightened by our distress which isn't
overly in love with the idea of seeming
at all times normal
which can allow us to be deranged for a
while in order one day to reach a more
authentic kind of sanity
it will help us immensely in this quest
if the images of mental illness we can
draw on at this time do not narrowly
imply that our ailment is merely a
freakish and pitiable possibility if we
can appeal to images that tease out the
universal and dignified themes of our
state so that we do not on top of
everything else have to fear and hate
ourselves for being unwell
we stand to heal a great deal faster if
there are fewer associations like those
created by goya of madness as the
seventh circle of hell
and more of men and women a little like
you and me sitting on the sofa able to
combine our inner wretchedness with
other more temperate and attractive
qualities
so that we remain every bit human
despite our terrifying convulsions
absences of mind catastrophic
forebodings and sense of despair
the best philosophical background
against which to wrestle with mental
unwellness
would be one that conceived of the human
animal as intrinsically rather than
accidentally flawed a philosophy that
would resolutely reject the notion that
we could ever be perfect and would
instead welcome our griefs and our
errors our stumbles and our follies as
no less a part of us than our triumphs
and our intelligence
it is japan's zen buddhism that has
historically perhaps best put forward
such notions with its bold declaration
that life itself is suffering and its
veneration in the visual arts and by
extension in its psychology of what is
imperfect and unglossy
rainy autumn evenings sadness
moss covered roofs
stained wooden panels tears and most
famously misshapen and irregular pieces
of pottery
against such a background it becomes a
great deal easier for us to accept
ourselves in our unwell state
we feel less guilty that we are not at
work and are not playing up to the roles
demanded of us by responsible others
we can be less defensive and frightened
more inclined to seek out proper care
and more likely to recover properly in
time
with a philosophy of acceptance in mind
we can recognize that whatever the
particularities of our crisis which will
naturally need to be investigated in due
course
our pains fit into a broad picture of a
crisis-prone human condition
no one is spared
no life can escape significant troubles
everything is imperfect
we don't have to know the details of
someone's life to be able to guess at
the scale of the difficulties they too
will have encountered
we have all been born to inadequate
parents our desires will always exceed
reality we will all make some appalling
errors we will hurt those we love and
anger those with power over us we will
be anxious and confused woeful and lost
we should accept both that we are
profoundly unwell
and that our ailments are entirely
normal
japanese philosophy has another lesson
for us at this point
we will probably one day be fixed but
there are likely to be substantial and
ineradicable marks
and yet these marks can be worn with
pride and self-respect
according to zen buddhism's tradition of
kintsugi an accidentally smashed bowl
isn't going to be thrown away in
embarrassment its pieces can be
carefully collected and reassembled with
glue inflected with gold
the traces of repair are made obvious
celebrated and cherished as if to
suggest to us as we bring a cup to our
lips that we do not have to give up on
ourselves
or be ashamed of our brokenness
we can confront our illness without
panic or fear with a quiet intelligent
sadness perhaps best captured by the
word
melancholy if we were searching for a
patron saint of such a melancholy
relationship to mental difficulty
we could do worse than pick the welsh
artist gwen john
who combined a brilliant career as a
painter with moments of harrowing mental
collapse
but remained all the while fundamentally
on the side of life
from her self-portrait john implies that
she would understand whatever we might
be going through her eyes hint that she
has been there too that she could be our
guide to the underworld of our minds
and that however we might hate ourselves
in this moment we deserve gentleness
patience and respect as we feel our way
towards repair
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected areas of life
such as finding a good enough partner
and mastering the art of confidence
click now to learn more